while we open this broadcast with those
striking comments made by former u.s
president
george w bush in an exclusive interview
with dw news he calls the withdrawal
of u.s and nato troops out of
afghanistan a mistake
while president bush added he feared
that the pull out of troops would lead
to women
and girls suffering at the hands of the
taliban he also spoke of his
relationship with german chancellor
angela merkel
praising her for her support of the
military mission in afghanistan
i was very pleased she was supportive of
troops in afghanistan
and by the way and and one of the
reasons why uh is because she saw
the progress that could be made for
young girls and women in afghanistan
it's unbelievable how
that society changed from the brutality
of the taliban
and all of a sudden you know sadly
uh i'm afraid afghan women and girls are
going to suffer unspeakable
harm is it a mistake it's a withdrawal
you know i think it is
yeah i think because i think the
consequences are going to be
unbelievably bad
and uh i'm sad and i spend
laura and i spend a lot of time with
afghan women and
uh and they're scared and
i think about all the interpreters and
people that helped not only us troops
but nato troops
and they're just it seems like this can
be left behind to be slaughtered by
these very brutal people and uh it
breaks my heart
that exclusive interview interview with
the former uh president conducted by our
washington bureau chief ines paul and we
can go to ines
right now to get some more insight
into what was being said very striking
comments there
inez give us a sense how he felt about
the pull out
yeah well he really thinks that this is
a huge mistake and
will lead to chaos in afghanistan what
he said and laila
you know this whole interview was said
in a very personal
take we could talk to him in his summer
home in maine
and i really believed what he said that
he
really is deeply concerned he's deeply
concerned what does he
fear most
well you know to give you a little bit
of a perspective on our international
viewers as many of the long-time
conservative republicans
bush also still believes that the goal
to fight
terrorism in the middle east was
necessary and
now he thinks it is far too dangerous to
leave afghanistan
to the taliban as they has really
started to make ground in the country so
this is kind of the bigger picture
now of course the current president of
president joe biden
very different uh approach he has
defended the rapid withdrawal from
afghanistan just last week
he said that america did not go to the
region to
do nation building let's take a listen
to what he said exactly and we'll
continue our conversation after that
we did not go to afghanistan to nation
build
and it's the right and the
responsibility of afghan people alone
to decide their future and how they want
to run their country
so what was enos president bush's
original objective
when he launched the war in afghanistan
two decades ago
well he initiated this war in
afghanistan as part of
his white house goal to fight the war on
terrorism after 1911 after the 9 11
attacks
leila we have to remember there was a
real fear about
global terrorism then not only in the
united states but all around the world
but
again after 20 years the war and
its tension kind of got muddled and and
became extremely
unpopular here in the united states and
also
around the world so it's very very
difficult to justify
its reason to stay in afghanistan you
were there with him in that very
intimate
setting that you outlined for us did you
get a feeling
that the former president president bush
was criticizing indirectly
uh president biden
well sure they obviously have a very
very different approach
biden wants to end this war because
he cannot justify the reasons to stay
and also it was actually former
president
trump who started the withdrawal i think
it wasn't really the intention of
president bush to criticize biden
directly because
we really mainly talked about angela
merkel and her legacy
but yes obviously they do have very
different takes
did you get a sense in conclusion that
he regrets
ever launching that war
i do not think so uh it is that
speculation but
as we just saw and heard in this little
clip you played leila
i think he really deeply believes that
the war was good for
mainly women and girls in afghanistan
and
uh was a possibility to really make
their lives better and that this
opportunity
that this possibility now is destroyed
by the withdrawal
washington borough chief inis oppo
reporting thank you very much
ali latifi is standing by in kabul
and he has extensively reported
from there and has been covering the
nato mission in afghanistan for years
so good to have you with us ali former
president bush weighing in you just
heard calling the withdrawal from
afghanistan a mistake
is that a view that is shared with the
people and the leadership
in afghanistan
i think the people of afghanistan they
knew that
i mean the writing was on the wall that
this you know intervent that this
invasion whatever you want to call it
was going to end at some point
and ever since trump was very obvious
that it was going to happen fairly soon
but what frustrates the avon people is
not neces you know they were saying if
you're going to go
go just tell us when but more than
anything
don't leave without some kind of
conditions you know there are no
conditions on the taliban there are no
conditions on the government
there is no real you know impetus to i
for either side to go
and seriously take on the peace talks in
doha right now there is no impetus on
the taliban for any kind of a ceasefire
or reduction in violence the fact that
they just said
we're leaving with no restrictions with
no um
with no conditions that's what's upset
the avalon people more than anything
no strings attached as you are uh
reporting
now uh he mentioned which was also quite
interesting in that exclusive
uh dw news report that the people that
he's most
worried about are the women the children
other vulnerable groups like the
interpreters and the people who helped
the troops that have been based in
afghanistan
for two decades what is their situation
right now
um you know the situation of
interpreters is difficult because they
were on the front lines of this you know
they were standing beside
foreign soldiers going into villages
they were involved in interrogations
although at that time their identities
were hidden
but it's fairly easy for the taliban to
figure out who these people were
now the taliban has issued a statement
saying if they really express
remorse or repentance for what they did
you know
they will let them go but there's no
guarantee of that because there's no
real system in place for that how can
you convince who are you supposed to
convince
and how can you convince them you know
enough
that you are quote unquote repentant
that they won't actually come after you
um so the situation for them is very
dire
the situation is very tired and can you
also speak to uh the situation of afghan
women
and uh children will the the
the gains that they have made uh in
these past couple of
years are they lost
well i think we have to remember that
you know these aren't gains necessarily
all of them a lot of them are regains
that you know
women had rights children had rights
before the soviet occupation you know
that things were evolving at that point
so it's not as if the us came and
magically all of these things appeared
um the other thing is that there have
been a lot of difficulties along the way
you know
uh women still have difficulties finding
jobs
access to education is still a major
issue
so to say that you know everything is
great at this moment
is also not necessarily realistic but of
course there is fear that if the taliban
come back to power that they may go back
to their old ways of
1996 where women besides doctors were
not allowed to step out of the house
where there were controls on what you
are
on you know media consumption
on all of those kinds of things so
that's why it's so important for the
taliban to really put out a list of
exactly what they expect if they are to
come to power
what will the legacy be of two decades
of u.s presence in afghanistan and what
do you make
of the former president the president
who launched
that that war in afghanistan to topple
the taliban
i think it's very interesting that he's
suddenly you know concerned about women
and children because you know
his war made a lot of widows and made a
lot of children orphaned you know there
was a lot of
you know there were there was there was
rendition there was guantanamo there was
imprisonments there was night raids
there was drone strikes there's
airstrikes
there's all kinds of things that if he's
concerned about civilians he should have
you know thought about during his own
administration
as for the legacy i mean the fact that
we're having these questions is a legacy
right the fact that the taliban is still
able to pose a threat
to to to the government and to the
security forces
uh the fact that we're still having
these battles and the fact that we're
still
asking what might happen to women to
children to interpreters
you know 20 years down the line that is
the legacy it
you know what really was achieved if
we're still asking these questions
20 years later ali latifiyah
journalist in kabul thank you so much
for weighing in greatly appreciate it
thank you and programming a note we'll
be broadcasting our exclusive interview
with the former u.s president george w
bush in full
here on dw news throughout the day he
also
talks extensively about german
chancellor angela merkel ahead of
her trip to the u.s to meet the current
president president joe biden starting
on thursday
and you can also watch it on our youtube
channel dw documentary